el lunes este pueblo a 40 kilómetros de
quieva amaneció en medio de la
desolación en plena noche la casa de
esta pareja de ancianos fue alcanzada
por un dron su garaje prendió en llamas
el hombre resultó herido
seguía vibrando muy fuerte Entonces se
produjo una explosión muy fuerte y nos
preguntamos Cómo acabaría todo esto para
nosotros
durante toda la noche las sirenas
sonaron en la región de quiebre objetivo
de otro asalto aéreo ruso el tercero en
sólo seis días una vez más la
infraestructura energética del país fue
blanco como la empresa donde trabaja
esta mujer que escuchó las explosiones
de camino al trabajo
[Música]
Estoy muy ansiosa ansiosa porque nunca
sabes cuándo se acercará a un misil Pero
en cuanto salta la alerta antiaérea
abandonamos inmediatamente la oficina
los ataques provocaron nuevos cortes de
agua y electricidad en kiev y 10
regiones del país mientras millones de
ucranianos siguen sumidos en la
oscuridad y el frío desde el pasado
viernes según el presidente Ucrania no
los drones responsables de los asaltos
son de fabricación iraní
anoche 34 drones iraníes sahead
volvieron a atacar Ucrania llegó su
cantidad y su nombre con mucha precisión
son del nuevo lote que Rusia recibió de
Irán
tras este ataque volvió a pedirle a
occidente que proporcione más armas a
Ucrania ya que sus efectivos temen un
posible ataque ruso contra principios de